this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
the ramsay show we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships we're glad
you're here george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print
podcast on the ramsey networks is my
co-host today the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five tom is going to start
us off from cleveland ohio this hour hi
tom how are you
good good how about you guys better than
we deserve brother what's up
um so
um i'm looking into becoming a real
estate agent but first um
if you're wondering
where the southern accent comes from
it's because i moved here from north
carolina okay and in in the process of
doing that um
i was
fortunate enough to
have the services of a local elp here
and i paid cash for my place here good
so um so so from that um
that
you know there that i'm i'm a baby step
seven guy
i
that has motivated me to become a real
estate agent and
in
talking with these ladies
it is being suggested that i start out
by
doing some investing in rental
properties
without becoming an agent i know i don't
need to be an agent to be to be a
landlord
but
my purpose in doing that is to
as you like to say get the boat close to
the dock before jumping ships
um
on a
full-time job
um
part of my motive
part of my motivation for becoming a
real estate agent is i'm visually
impaired and
i want to bring
a relatable experience to those others
who are visually impaired
so
today my question is how do i even get
started in real estate investing
i get i hear you use words like cash on
cash
and i'm not entirely sure
what we mean by that
okay
um answer that one first cash on cash
rate of return is how much cash you put
in versus how much cash you get out
so if the rental property makes you ten
thousand dollars net profit after all
expenses in a year
and you paid one hundred thousand
dollars for it your cash on cash is a
ten percent rate of return
okay now that makes that makes perfect
yeah okay if it's a two hundred thousand
dollar cash investment into the property
and you pull out ten thousand dollars
then you have a five percent cash on
cash rate of return
if you only pay cash for properties cash
on cash is the only rate of return that
there is
well actually there's an internal rate
of return too but the the you know
there's um
if you're leveraging meaning borrowing
money into real estate then you would
use some other measures as well but i
don't i look at just i put i put in some
cash how much cash am i getting back as
a result of that what's my return on
investment same thing with them with a
mutual fund you put you know 100 000 in
and they send you 12 000 then you made
12 on your money
right same thing
that's a cash on cash rate of return is
what that means now i uh
i do not think that i do not agree that
this is the best method for you to
become a real estate agent
really
really i i i have never
i mean almost never known someone i knew
some real estate investors who later
decided
to become agents but i i can't think of
in 30 years of doing real estate that
i've run into someone who said oh i'm
going to be a real estate investor so
that i can be an agent
i just wouldn't do it i think that's a
long i think that's a long play
um
what are you doing now for work tom
so i'm working and okay so that's that
was i was just gonna tell you i'm uh
working at an amazon facility
um
where we
load boxes and all that good stuff what
do you make and
um
we're 15.50 an hour so that's what
you're living with are you married
negative
miss wright and i haven't met each other
yet okay so where did you get all the
money to be a baby step seven guy making
15 bucks working boxes at amazon
oh well
not i didn't i inherited some and
i started off in 1998 with a
little place that i paid like 75 000
for and i paid that off
with um so you made money on your houses
and that led you into yet another house
that's now paid for you've just been
very careful correct
correct and then you make enough at your
at your profession to eat
correct okay cool all right so what do
you make a year what do you make a year
doing boxes on amazon
we're i'm right at 30. okay
so the bad news is you only make only
companies hate my gut yeah the bad news
is that yes yeah but the bad news is you
only make 30. the good news is it
doesn't take a lot to replace that
so won't you go get a real estate
license and start selling houses on the
side while you're doing boxes
can you can you do that sure i mean
i don't i've never
i'm not i don't know how all this works
yeah what's the extent of your of your
visual impairment how blind are you
i can see well enough to get around and
that's pretty much it you wouldn't want
me behind the wheel okay so you don't
drive
correct but you could walk through a
house with someone and it wouldn't be a
major problem you can i i assume you've
got some technology where you can access
the internet and utilize that right
correct okay all right good well i think
you can be a real estate agent and by
the way i think it's wonderful that you
uh can
help people that have similar
impairments to what you've got
i think that's a great mission it's too
small a market to make a living in
so i'd like for you to i'd like for you
to do that i'd like to sell i'd like you
to sell everybody houses and some of
them be sight impaired and you've got a
special uh
uh you're gonna be a special help to
them the to the side impaired folks but
that's not a big enough market for you
to make a living in i understand and
that's that's um that's a consideration
of mom yeah tom my dad did this later in
life he's a full-time civil engineer and
he got his real estate license on the
side much like you he wanted to help
people in our local church that were
immigrating here find homes and so to
this day he still does that on the site
for fun but it's it's a hobby for him
it's not how he puts food on the table
yeah but dude if you sell three or four
houses a year you'll make more than 30.
it won't take long yeah so go get your
license and then once you get once you
get a little bit of income coming in
from the real estate you can drop the
amazon gig and be like a real estate guy
and then save up some money and if you
want to be a real estate investor later
with some cash meaning you pay cash for
your rental properties then fine
but uh the idea that you have to go buy
three rental properties so that you're a
landlord so you can relate to a buyer is
absolutely no no it's just not true
it's not a path that is normally used
and it's i mean there's very
be hard-pressed to find somebody that
did it actually that way yeah i just
hadn't run into them i mean um
you know a lot of real estate investors
that you know
do a few deals with their license here
there
um and i know a lot of real estate
agents who have never owned a single
piece of property except the one they
live in
that's okay too and that's actually
very normative
most real estate agents don't have a
real estate portfolio
so most of them don't they just don't
hope that helps man thanks for the call
george campbell with me this hour this
is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free homeownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means to live life to the
fullest
picture all your favorite speakers
together on one stage on one stage
empowering you with the tools the
principles that'll create unstoppable
momentum that is smart conference
it's not just another pep talk we're
going to talk to you about your
relationships your mental wellness your
leadership your money
yeah we're going to talk to you about
your marriage we're going to talk to you
about your career yeah and when you
leave after being with us all day on
saturday the 22nd in dallas 22nd of
october in dallas you will be smarter
all the ramsey personalities will be
speaking along with craig and amy
groschel from life church doing uh
doing a talk on money event passes start
at only 39
that is a great price for a full day
event like this get your passes now
before they sell out
get to ramsey solutions dot com slash
events
you can learn
even more
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five sherry is in
peoria illinois hi sherry how are you
hi i'm good hi dave hi george hey what's
up
uh nice to talk to you again i met you
at your smart conference um in 2019 my
husband i went to so cool very very
exciting day so yes
um
my question is i'm 49 my husband is 60.
um we're in the process of selling our
rentals right now because we did do it
backwards before we um came into the
plan
so we do have our house paid off our
personal residence and then i said we're
selling our rentals we also just bought
his dad's farm
and moving to that so
when our house sells and all the rentals
sell we have two more
um we're going to be real estate heavy
as opposed to then our retirement
accounts so
um
i have 112 000 in mine and my husband
only has 33. so my question is
how do we
i want to concentrate on his because
he's going to be 62 here soon
we will be taking his social security at
62 and we plan on investing that
we are self-employed i do work outside
the home but he's self-employed
contractor
we're planning on putting the business
in in my name so he can continue after
age 62 to continue working
because i think you're capped out at a
certain amount when you start taking
your social security so we're just
looking for some investment for
retirement advice um
you know should we put into ross
um nick i haven't put any money into
mine since we've been together we've
been married for 14 years
so we're just looking for some guidance
so how much cash are you going to have
the farm will be paid for
finally paid for it'll be worth um
probably about 650. okay and you're
gonna have a pile of cash from the sale
of everything else how big
well that's um like our house right now
is on the market for 270
um and then we have two rentals
that we still have mortgages on
we are looking to make
57 000 1 approximately 47 on another and
we're hoping to get about 250 on our so
we may still have like a small mortgage
of about 20 25 000
to finish paying off when we get done
because we're going to put everything to
the to the
uh mortgage on the farm
oh so the farm has a mortgage
the farm yeah we did take a mortgage out
of that because we have our person so
what do you owe on the mortgage audio on
the farm like 350.
3.97 yeah okay all right so you're not
going to have any money okay
um well we have our emergency yeah but i
mean you're going to be you're going to
use all of this to try to clear that
mortgage as soon as possible
yeah and then your baby step four is
what it amounts to you're putting 15
percent of your income aside until you
reach
until you get that mortgage paid off and
then you're going to load up everything
and um yeah i'm with you i'd load
everything you can
into his account because it doesn't
matter i mean you could put it into his
but i just load everything into roths
and uh as much as you can you're gonna
want to load up everything
okay so that's my question too like do
we do roth first yeah do we do his step
either one's fine i mean you can do you
can do a cell phone you can do a sep
roth
okay yeah and i don't want to make him i
don't think you need i'm not sure we're
going to take his social security i
think you can leave it sit there for a
little bit if you're worried about that
i think he needs to just keep running
that business and make a big pile of
money over the next 10 years
okay and let's just load this up load
this up intercept roths load the roths
uh do you have anything available at
your work
um i will be finding that out because
this is my third year work in there so
now i'm eligible i will be getting a
self check from them so whatever they
put into theirs
um
like the 20s like last year they put 25
into the employees but they don't have
anything other than they don't have
anything other than a shop no
yeah
all right yeah
load him up a sep load you up a couple
of raw each of you have a roth and then
load yours that way you know you don't
have any choice they're going to put
what they're going to put in your sep so
yeah just max all that out and and let's
get the farm paid off and so with a paid
off farm how big a pile of money can we
build outside of that in in retirement
and sit down your smart investor pro and
you can even do some more there once the
farm's paid off doesn't have to be all
inside of retirement but i would i would
load up these retirement accounts for
sure and she's about to be 50 so there
should be some catch-up contributions
depending on the types of accounts
she can
put they've just got the
they can do a little larger roth is all
it amounts to yeah there's not a catch
up on a sap
and both of the others are set that's
all they've got could the farm become
income producing at some level
uh depending on what they do with it
yeah i guess you farm it i mean if you
put
something on there that might create
some income that'd be nice to add to the
equation yeah but let's get his business
going and then let's just load up the
retirements you can once the house once
the farm's paid off and then let's pay
off then let's see how big a pile of
just regular investments and mutual
funds we can have and when you've got no
payments you don't need as much in
retirement which is nice and you can
build a lot yeah so go ahead and let's
try to get you know half a million
million dollars in there before we slow
down too much
um because you know we're talking
she's got two decades he's got a decade
at least
minimum of work time available so let's
go let's go bust let's go get some money
you know i mean that's what amounts to
philip is in new york city hi phillip
how are you
i'm doing okay it's great to talk to you
guys sure what's up
so uh my wife and i are in baby step two
uh we've been there for about two years
now and you know probably have about two
years left realistically um and i know
you recommend trying to do it in three
we're doing our best so i'm curious if
your thoughts on that but we have a
third kid on the way we're both working
and coordinating child care has gotten
to be crazy with two and three sounds
even more crazy i've always wanted to
have her be at home she wants that also
but uh you know we're just concerned
about you know getting through baby step
two
and losing her income and so i really
like your thoughts on
how to go about doing this and whether
or not that's a really curtain idea what
do you make
started when we first started what do
you make now
i take home 14 dollars a month you do
yes what do you do
i'm a psychologist okay and what does
she make
she she takes home fifty thousand a year
so five five thousand dollars a month
for ten months she doesn't get paid in
the summer she's a reading specialist
great
because a reading specialist can do
tutoring from home with her kids
and she could probably make 50 doing
that
yeah i we actually had considered that
um but with the baby at home i guess i'm
not sure how she would actually do the
tutoring from home
well during nap time
we just kept our one-year-old and you
know
uh our our son's one-year-old for the
weekend and
um we got the benefit of enjoying nap
time
yeah i guess it feels like a huge risk
to
to do that and uh you know i trusted
myself to build the business that i did
when i left a more stable job and went
into private practice and i guess it's
making the same kind of leap but i had
some i was doing it part time before
moving full-time how much debt do you
have left
uh
198 thousand dollars we started at what
student loans uh student loans there
yeah
well i i'm fine with her coming home you
all just got to work your budget out on
14k but it's pretty easy for her
early in this process maybe not the
first three months or whatever but early
in the process to start doing some
tutors and tutors and reading specialist
tutors are making 50 grand or 50 an hour
right now
and so uh reading specialists are in
high demand
and so there's no reason at all you
can't get a lot of private tutor set up
to the extent that she can do that i
don't think you have to count on it it's
not high risk
but yeah you can do that
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage austin
and brown are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you good to have you
guys where do you all live
san antonio texas all right good good to
have you how much debt have you paid off
271 thousand
dollars and ninety eight cents love it
how long did this take seven years all
right and your range of income during
that time anywhere from 132 to 160
we dipped and
did all sorts of stuff during that all
kinds of gyrations what do y'all do for
a
living
i'm an in-house counsel for a specialty
insurance company group okay
and i am a nurse and then i have a small
etsy shop too oh good good for you guys
all right so seven years 271 000 that's
your mortgage
i wish oh no
no student loans and kitchen appliances
that we have since had to replace
washer and dryer cars medical bills
credit cards
you name it we got it you were kind of
normal yes and it was a mess yes
yes but we got a lawyer and you said a
nurse right yes
a big student loans big student loans
stupid students how much of the 271 was
student loans oh i think 160
that's what it was when we started after
interest i'm not sure how much it was
wow bright side of cove no interest wow
so what happened seven years ago that
put you guys on this journey i think it
actually happened about eight years ago
our marriage went through a really rough
time um
and lots of different aspects but when
we decided we needed to reconcile we
needed to reconcile completely
and redo everything we were doing with
our marriage and that included
our yes absolutely so we
started looking into your plan and i
kind of started doing it just with my
credit card to see
how it would work and it worked
fabulously so then we brought it when we
put our income back together after that
separation we just went for it wow good
good cool so did you go through
financial peace university at that point
or you just read the book or what we
read the book and we listened to a lot
of
of your show whenever we passed the the
bmw
car slot my son who was just
six five years old he thought that was
your office he'd be like look there's
bmw
that's amazing yeah
where the paid off home mortgage is
taking the place of the bmw
dave's over at the
bmw that's good that's fun very cool wow
that's a long track y'all it is
it was it worth it absolutely
absolutely what was it like paying off
appliances you didn't even own anymore
is that frustrating
it absolutely was and you know when
you're
when you're paying them with a credit
card you don't really look into
everything you just oh i can afford this
and you just hand over your credit card
but then when we had to replace all
those appliances we really looked into
reviews and how much things cost it it
changes the way your mind works so that
you pay attention what's your own money
absolutely absolutely when it's real
money yeah instead of fake money
borrowed money yeah yes very good cool
and during that time we were able to
cash flow pretty much everything we did
we we had a whole nother human during
that
and then
those new appliances and some we went on
some small vacations during that time
since it was such a long long time yes
and some emergency trips but
we made it wow very cool
so was anybody from the outside you're
outside your family cheering you on
did you have any cheerleaders outside
your family oh for sure her parents
were very strong
role models
for us
both spiritually and um and that
financial leadership type role yeah yes
and they're the ones that insisted we
come here today oh wow instead of just
calling so they helped helped us get
here today too wow
even with that so that's fun yeah well
it's good to celebrate a milestone this
big it's taking this long to get to yes
absolutely they're right this is very
important very good
proud of you so what was what was the
biggest sacrifice you guys had to make
along the way that really was hurt
probably golf for him oh
not that i'm good um but i like spending
money on the course
so that was out of the picture for for a
while there correct are you back at it
now a little bit still just as bad as
you were yes okay good nothing's changed
wow that's awesome wow well good for you
guys well done very proud of you what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
just keep trekking along i think and the
the budget too is a huge for us once we
for me anyway once we put the budget
together it kind of felt like we were
getting that raise to where okay we have
this much
little spending we have every month and
before it was like we've
had none so just
doing that budget and actually sticking
to it
very cool good job you guys good job hey
we got a copy of the latest number one
bestseller that we've done uh baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too
that's the next chapter for you yeah
you're gonna be baby steps millionaires
next year i hope so yes you are we're
ready you're on your way
the people in this book did just exactly
what you're doing so i'm proud of you
very well done
and also a copy of total money makeover
which was your guide on this process you
can hand that off to somebody and get
them going and uh a one-year
subscription to financial peace
university awesome so we'll get you guys
signed up for that and for the every
dollar uh the uh upgrade on every dollar
so you got the best budgeting app going
you got the whole package here going so
we'll make sure you guys get into that
next gear now uh and move on uh now that
you've come through really the hardest
part
and and now now you're in the position
to build wealth so very well done thank
you great job you bring the kids with
you bring them up let's get their names
and ages
so we've got brady and he is 12. and
lola is 10 and then cece cecilia is four
all right very well done good job you
guys well we're honored to have you
we're proud of you heroes well done you
took control of your life yes in a whole
bunch of different areas yes very very
important good stuff austin and brown
brady lola and cece from san antonio
texas 271 000 paid off in seven years
132 to 160 000 income count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one that's how it's done
cece just left the stage she couldn't
handle it it was too much for her
she's bouncing all over the wall exited
stage left
that's fun stuff that's awesome a
marriage restored a family tree change
that's why we do this that's good it
gets old that's good that's the thing
and here's the thing folks um
what they recognized seven years ago in
that process is something that a bunch
of you need to recognize because it's
the best route for you it's the most
effective route for you is that
these things in our life
our marriage our kids our
finances our health
are not stand-alone
subjects they're interwoven with each
other your mental wellness
your career these things all affect each
other
and so when you start working on the
whole package you
and a part of that is we lead you to
financial peace you go to financial
peace university part of that is you
know you're plugging in with dr john
dolone and you're learning some
boundaries with your family and you're
learning that you're worth being loved
and you know good wellness issues mental
wellness issues and uh you know you walk
around this building and you start
plugging these things in your life your
life starts to round out and every one
of these subjects gets better
simultaneously your marriage your
parenting has changed because financial
stress when you take that off the table
a whole bunch of stuff is affected
positively yeah well taking up brain
space you're burning a lot of brain
calories when you're stressed about
money and it's it's going to be hard to
have a great marriage and if your career
sucks it's hard to come home and have a
great life when you get home when you're
carrying that around and so we want you
to get better in all of these areas and
that's part of why we've expanded this
thing ken coleman helping people find
that career path john delaney helping
people get well and it all matters it's
all interconnected
absolutely george campbell ramsey
personality my co-host today this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today megan is in phoenix hi
megan welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave i am so happy like to talk to
you i've been like dying to talk to you
forever and i've been following you for
like five to six years so much
well thanks how can we help today
hi okay so my question my main question
is
this um and then you can ask me whatever
okay so i have a 401k from my previous
employer that i no longer work for
and there's about 6k in there
and um i was wondering if i can pull it
out and use for a down payment on a
house
i would be a first time home buyer
and i i'm not paying any rent right now
which
is good
at the same time i guess
how old are you going to want to get a
house i'm 32. okay i'm about to be 32.
well the short answer and the long
answer is no don't do that
because the penalties you're going to
pay on the money you take out is going
to crush it and it's only six thousand
how quickly could you save up six
thousand
um
i i have
i want to say like in six months okay
and we're just trying to get like we're
before the housing market just like gets
crazy yeah too late
it's already crazy
crazy if i'm you i'm rolling it over to
an ira direct rollover to an ira so that
you have control of it and let that
money grow for you over the next 30
years of your career
here's the problem megan if you take it
out you're going to get a hit with a 10
penalty plus your tax rate so it's gonna
be like borrowing money at 30 interest
for a down payment you would never do
that
okay so don't do it george is right sam
is in toronto hey sam welcome to the
ramsey show hi thanks for taking my call
sure what's up hi
i've got a bit of a family question um
i've been my parents uh grew up and
we're very very frugal and
i found out a while ago that they're
pretty well off because they're so
frugal and uh i've been i've been
involved in just helping my parents make
some decisions and and do some things
going forward because i've got an
interest in it and and i'm
pretty frugal and good with money myself
um
but now i've i've got two siblings
and they don't have i would say as good
a relationship with money
and
my parents i think are kind of
struggling
but i don't think my siblings really
understand that my parents have some
money and and my parents want to be able
to give them some money in a way that's
not destructive to them
and uh
they were considering you know some some
pretty substantial gifts to maybe help
them with uh buying houses and that sort
of thing
and i'm just i'm just they asked me what
i think about it and i'm i'm just a
little nervous about
um giving people who who don't have a
great relationship with money
too much money at once or helping them
out too much where
you know they might they might not
strive for as much if they get too much
help um
with their life
well
your parents are making you the middle
man here to decide
well not really making me the middle man
they just they
they they were asking what i think they
trust your opinion because you've
managed money well
and so they don't want to ruin it
i
i really i really at a young age really
liked learning about investments and
money and that sort of thing and
uh at one point my dad said well why
don't you take a look at my stuff and i
was really surprised and i found out
that you had quite quite a bit of money
and i actually how old are your siblings
sam
uh late twenties and early thirties okay
um i i think your dad and mom just need
to sit down with them individually and
say
guys um we've done pretty well
and we've done pretty well with money
because we've handled it well and we're
not going to be able to give it to
people who don't handle it well
and so we're we want to help you guys
get better at handling money and we want
you to go through a class called
financial peace university or we want
you to do this or read this book or do
whatever
uh or you have to you have to watch 5
000 debt free screams i don't know
whatever it is right but um somehow they
need to communicate this to them and
it's not your place to do that it's
their place to do that
so
um you know if it was my kid i would sit
down and go look i ca i manage money for
god and it's my job to pass it on to
people who can manage it well and um i
can't pass it to you because you're not
managing it well
and i'm not going to finance your i'm
not going to finance your misbehavior
your immaturity your impulsiveness your
whatever it is and so um you know i'd
really be honored to come alongside you
coach you help you get you know learn to
do some of these things and then we
would be able to really reach over and
do some substantial things to help you
guys in your lives but we really can't
do that right now because we're not
comfortable doing that
and if you if you want to just keep
living like you're living then we can't
you know we're prohibited we will be
really sad that you chose to
uh not receive these gifts that these
financial gifts that we have prepared
for you
okay
yeah and i i think you know i think you
just got to call them out and go guys
you know and it's not controlling it's
just look if you want to do this this is
the this is the um
the path i mean and
uh
you know have have some suggestions of
the class you want to take the books you
want to bring whatever it is and then
you want to observe that they are now
being
mature responsible adults with money so
we can put some stipulations on this
gift because it's our money and we can
do what we want with it yeah and i you
know and it's okay if you don't want to
do it i'm not trying to control your
life i'm just controlling my life
and so if i'm going to do this and you
know we do the same thing ramsey found
ramsey family foundation does not give
money to
ministries that are poorly run
you know that's a bad investment of
god's money and so if you're
operationally moronic i can't i can't
put money into that can't subsidize two
people what they do is really sweet i'm
glad it's really sweet but they're
really bad at it
you know they're bad at being sweet and
so you know it's the same thing and and
you've got to just it's not being cold
it's not being mean or sarcastic or
smart like it's it's quite the opposite
of all of that it's an act of love well
you don't want to be an enabler either
it's exactly it bethany's in new york
city hi bethany how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so i'm in the process of purchasing a
house and right now i have enough saves
to cover both the
house and the closing costs the down
payment the closing cost
and i've been listening to you for a
week and so now i'm really and i paid
off my student loan yesterday 10k
and now i'm supercharged and i wanted to
wipe out um my
auto loan as well with the house so if i
do both of that i'm only left with about
three thousand dollars so my question
for you
is if i should go all in or if i should
just wait for the house to close let it
settle and then see what happens first
before moving towards the autonomous
you need to get in the house and get
settled before you pay off the car
because i don't want something
unexpected to come up this four thousand
dollars in this process and you only
have three
you're down too tight in the middle of
buying a house uh of course we would
have recommended you wait until you were
debt-free but you already had all this
in process before you found us
yeah yeah so
um what's left on the car
it's 23 000. yeah
so yeah you'll have 26 000 in the bank
if everything goes as planned
plus your emergency fund when you move
into the house is that right
yes
okay and then you'll write a check
and pay off the car you know get in the
house get settled two two weeks three
weeks in the house
and make sure all your bills are paid
all your stuff's set up everything's
moved around and then write a check when
you're closing on the house
uh well it's supposed to go june 30th
but it became a short sale so now we
just don't know that they have until
june 30th where i can back out of the
deal
okay all right so you'll be done in a
couple weeks
yeah yeah it's not that big a deal yeah
let's get settled into that house and
then you'll know what you're dealing
with and then get the car paid off as
soon as possible after that
but um so it's good that you're excited
about becoming debt-free yeah i like
that part
just to recap for those of you listening
we would tell you to be 100 debt-free
have your emergency fund in place before
you contract for a house
and uh so that these things get these
things in the right order because it's
going to give you a lot less risk but
she found us
after she had already had the house
under contract and so you're obviously
not going to tell her to break her word
on that so
good stuff good question thank you for
joining us that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books our thanks to
austin penn zach andrew and james in the
booth i am dave ramsey your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five this is the ramsey show we
help people build wealth
do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print on ramsey networks is
my co-host today as we take your
questions about life and money again
triple eight eight two five five two two
five brian in columbia south carolina
starting off this hour hey brian what's
up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
so um recently i have taken over the
affairs
of a senior citizen at our church who we
affectionately call grandpa and in
looking over his finances um i've seen
that he's been signed up for some time
in the past two whole life policies so i
know that you're against whole life and
we were just talking about our options
on what to do with it and so if we cash
out the whole life uh to get rid of it
uh between the two policies that he
signed up for he would get a return of
twenty nine hundred dollars um which is
plenty of dollars from what he's paid my
question is
um they also offered us an option of him
freezing the policy so he pays no more
in it and he gets twenty two hundred
dollars upon his death if we choose to
do that now we at first i just thought
to cash it out and if we do cash it out
because he's got a pending medicaid
application which tends to take over
their finances to help provide that
long-term care how do we secure this
money in order to make sure that his
final stages just so it goes towards his
final stages when he does pass
medicaid won't take twenty nine hundred
bucks if it was two hundred ninety
thousand they would get into it
but they're not gonna fall between nine
hundred bucks it's not that's not gonna
mess him up on that yeah i'd just get
out of the whole life business and
you know i'd rather him have twenty nine
hundred dollars in the bank than twenty
two hundred dollars when he dies
right because he's got twenty nine
hundred dollars when he dies
right
does he have any money okay
no he just is on social which is the
basic 1200 a month
that's that's what he has currently yeah
and i'm sure there's some kind of a need
he has around there then
or at least a need for a little bit of a
baby emergency fund which this can
supply right
yes absolutely yes yeah
how old is he so what i just he's 83.
okay
and the face of the policies if he dies
is twenty two hundred dollars
well the policies are ten thousand each
oh okay if they can't we do cash out to
close it
i thought you said he got 2200 if he
died
well the 2200 is if we do a they call it
a reduced
freeze so he doesn't pay anything else
um at all on the account
for the policy and then upon his death
he gets that
2200
between those two policies on his death
in addition to the face value
no
no because if we freeze it out then he
doesn't pay anything
he's paid for a else 000 policy all
these years and these bozos say hey
we're going to help you out because
you're a good long-term customer instead
of paying you 10 000 at your death we're
going to pay you 2200 at your death but
you don't have to pay any more payments
how sweet how sweet what crooks
yes as if the others
as if the other 7
800
on an 83 year old won't pay the premiums
right what buttholes and he's almost
paid that ten thousand dollars over the
last three or four years he's been
signed up for every day oh easy easy
easy yeah oh my god sad what a how is
this legal still this is crazy it's just
yeah and act like they're doing you a
favor well we'll give you 20 200 bucks
oh you call it good
yeah you know watch these guys when
they're kissing you they'll pee on your
leg oh my god it's unbelievable
wow
yeah oh oh man that's unbelievable all
right so yeah you gotta uh you gotta
cash these things in man get away from
this company as fast as you can this is
just ridiculous
oh sad
whole life policies people this is the
companies that you're dealing with
this guy's paid into these policies he's
paid 15 000 in these policies and if you
put that fifteen thousand dollars during
that time in this ten thousand dollar
policy that they're offering to help him
with the 2200
he would have a hundred thousand dollars
he would have been better off with a
cookie if he put that in a mutual fund
he'd have a hundred thousand dollars
easy
easy
see they ought to just have their butts
kicked
and then walk around acting like
ramsay dave ramsey didn't know anything
about money well discuss my calculator
works this is a math thing
geez
fascinating that the biggest fans of
whole life are the whole life sales
people they're the only fans that's how
you know it's a scam they're the only
fans
yeah
oh i can't breathe all right i got to
move on melissa is with us in
jacksonville florida hey melissa what's
up
hey dave how are y'all great how can we
help
um so last july my husband and our
family moved for his job and we bought a
home
and then unfortunately in september he
lost that job and so ever since then
he's been trying to find another job
and
it seems as though we're going to have
to move again
he's got a job offer that's in wisconsin
this time
so what we're trying to figure out now
is
um whether to sell or rent our home
we're going to get a home provided for
us there when we move to wisconsin
so we're not really sure what to do
about our house so we're a little
weary of selling it
i'm a little leery of you keeping it
oh it's okay
you don't need a house in jacksonville
florida if you're living in wisconsin
yeah but it's like home around here so
it's kind of fun it's like home but it's
not home you're living in wisconsin
yeah
so what kind of work does he do that it
took him from september to now to find a
job in the hottest job market in the
history of mankind
well he works in hotel management and he
has been working jobs but he's doing a
lot of traveling so right now he's in
dallas
so it's been a lot of him being away
from our family
so
he's been doing like um independent
contract jobs you guys want to go to
wisconsin
i want our family to be together again
amen
i'm with you on that so you're willing
to live in wisconsin to make that happen
yes absolutely yeah okay
wow
um
so he's got a job as a big box manager
again or what
well he wants to get away from hotels
because it has been really
crazy the last couple years oh i thought
you said retake
no he's been in hotel management
so
he's gonna try something different he's
going to do a
campground management now
okay
um
[Music]
because that's what got offered to him
exactly not because last september he
set out to be a campground manager
all right i'm gonna send you a copy of
ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose if you take the job in wisconsin
and you move sell the house in
jacksonville but i think you need to
look for a different job i think he just
took something because it wasn't put in
front of him and they made him feel good
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
let's
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit ch chministries.org budget don't
worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
well george this series you did is a big
hit and i'm really glad that it is
because it's a great
job you guys did on this thank you if
you guys haven't heard we have a new
confidence in your coverage
your free five-day guide to insurance
it's a series of videos by george
campbell helping you understand your
insurance so you don't get screwed
and uh you don't end up buying like a
whole life or something right oh my gosh
every f every day for five days ramsey
personality george campbell will walk
you through a new insurance topic
unpacking everything you need to know to
get the right coverage it's completely
free to go through
and uh i'm really glad you guys are
watching this out there number one
george did a great job with it it's
always fun and funny if it's george
because he's like the nice one around
here and that kind of stuff it's a good
personal brand to have it's a good brand
you're the happy version of us yeah so
uh i'm happy too and indifferent i'm
happy you're doing this you're angry
it's angry happy yeah dave's happy to
not have time
i didn't have to do this i'm happy you
did it
but it's a really really good series so
uh you want to learn about insurance
it's free go to ramseysolutions.com
slash confidence again it's a five-day
series of
of uh videos by george unpacking
different insurance topics very quick
very easy they're all under three
minutes all under three minutes okay so
there you go that's my attention span so
i figured let's make videos that cater
to my attention span oh so you're the
focus group
i love it our new confidence in your
coverage five days of free guide to
insurance check it out
ramseysolutions.com
confidence mackenzie's with us mackenzie
is in texas
hi mckenzie how are you
good how are y'all better than we
deserve what's up
so i'm 19 and still in college um my
parents are going through fps so i've
kind of just been doing it with them i
do have an emergency fund but i just
kind of wanted to know from y'all's
perspective what the next steps for me
should be i don't have any student loans
um
and i'm paying for everything pretty
much myself that isn't covered by
scholarship
and how are you doing that you're
telling me
so
it's a lot of it is covered um like my
last semester i think i paid 30 dollars
so it's not like i'm
throwing a big chunk of money at it
every semester but um i do have
scholarships based on my academics and
then my father was in the military so a
lot of us covered by that oh very good
cool so you got gi bill and you got
academic scholarships and you're going
what's the school you're going to
texas state great and what are you
studying
marketing i love you you're awesome
you're doing this you're doing this
brilliantly if we could clone you and
make people in america have as much
common sense as you do we'd have a whole
lot better place amen way to go well
thank you so what i want you to do is i
want you to pile up as much cash as you
can pile up until you graduate
big old pile of cash
because the bigger apollo cash you have
that's your insurance policy to ensure
you complete this degree with no debt
yes sir if there's any little hiccup in
one of the little pilot one of the
little scholarships or something or some
kind of little delay then you don't
hiccup into a student loan you hiccup
into that big old emergency fund and
let's just pretend it went crazy let's
say you had like 50 000
or something
when you graduated
that'd be nice that'd be great you know
and you didn't have to use it right and
so what would you have well you'd have
the ability to move into the new place
new job get your life started maybe even
a down payment on the next on the first
house you'd you know you you're gonna
get plenty of use of that money before
you're 25 and in the meantime it's an
insurance policy investing in the best
investment i know of and that's an
investment called mckenzie
okay so just piling it up are you
working right now mackenzie during
college yes sir i work cool what do you
make and what do you do
um i work for geek squad
for best buy and i make
16.50 an hour
it's awesome and you're doing that what
10 15 20 hours a week
uh try to stay at a minimum of 25 hours
a week wow
you're impressive and you still you're
still completing your coursework and
getting good grades
yes sir
ding ding ding dave i thought you got a
word you are you are what's next you are
what's called employable
because you actually will you'll come
out with a degree with no debt and a
work ethic
you're like a known this you're a genius
this is amazing i love your parents it's
incredible your parents have done a
great job they've got to be so proud of
you that's just cool this is inspiring
they're out there
they're out there and there's more
mckenzie's than people know that's right
all we hear all we hear about is the
deadbeat version of you know i want to
go 40 000 in debt a year to play beer
pong and get a degree in left-handed
puppetry in german polka history and be
double major and i'll be a 40 year old
barista
you know oh my god you know instead we
have mackenzie who's going to take over
the freaking world she's going to have a
marketing job straight out of college
with a big pile of money with ramsey
solutions yeah we'll hire her in a
heartbeat you definitely
i mean that's one that gets through the
interview process right there because i
don't have to teach you how to work
that's a nice amazing idea you know wow
wow awesome scott's with us in portland
maine hey scott how are you
good dave and george how are you great
man how can we help
no i i want to thank you for for taking
my call and you changed my life and my
wife's life uh next month we'll be debt
free paying off about 75 000
and we owe it all to you and your
teaching well we're proud of you man we
didn't pay it off you did good job
thank you thank you so we're 35 years
old and we actually manage a horse
rescue and farm
in maine and we live on the farm rent
free
we plan on living out our career here
but we want to buy a house or land in
state by
retirement and possibly for rental
income and we're just wondering where we
should put that money that we set aside
year after year
how much money are we talking we're
hoping to set aside uh between 10 and 20
000 a year
okay and what's the time horizon here
uh we'd we'd love to buy something and
say 10 years maximum and and ideally not
have much if any of a mortgage
yeah
yeah and in the meantime i'm going to
just park it in something like an uh s p
500 index fund
and just park it in a simple mutual fund
and let it grow because you need it to
grow as fast as the real estate market's
growing and mutual funds will keep up
with the market roughly sometimes they
outperform the market the real estate
market and then when you actually buy
real estate then of course you're
keeping up with the market
and so the way you hedge
against inflation if you heard that
phrase i need a hedge against inflation
all that means is we buy something that
gives us as good a rate of return as the
inflation rate
and so if the inflation rate is eight
percent if you have a hedge that's two
percent it ain't hedging
okay right right it's 12 now you got a
hedge
and that's what we're talking about so
you're
that that's that's exactly what you need
to do is to measure into something like
that yeah and you can use a compound
interest calculator online and plug in
some different numbers to get a ballpark
of what this money might grow into over
that 10 years and start planning around
that
yeah it's gonna more than
yeah it's gonna he's gonna do real well
on that it's gonna be fine yeah that's a
good place 20k a year for 10 years yeah
with some compound growth i like that
excellent excellent job open phones here
at triple eight eight two five
george a lot of folks are asking a lot
of questions about real estate rachel
and i were talking about it earlier in
the week
um
this is a very unusual real estate
market right now
and then i can honestly tell you in the
next six months
that uh and i don't think this advice
will change during this this coming six
months
real estate is going to go up in value
every year for the next five years it's
not going to go up as much as it has
been
but a lot of people are saying i'm gonna
wait on houses to come back down you
can't find the time in history that real
estate went down except one
when you go back in recent fifty seventy
five hundred years okay you gotta go
back to the great depression to find two
the only other time is 2008 it went down
which was an anomaly and it was it
stayed down because it was a real estate
bubble that burst okay this is not a
bubble
this is real estate prices shot up we
had a supply demand curve issue and the
prices are not going to go down they're
going they're going not going to
continue to go up as fast as they have
been that's good news that's what we
mean by cool the market is cooling down
yeah but if you're saying i'm go i'm out
of debt i've got my emergency fund i'm
ready to buy a house this is the best
time in the next five years for you to
buy a house because every year you wait
it's gonna be more you're gonna be mad
at us in five years if you waited
they're gonna be mad at me because i
told you to do it so now's the best time
to do it if you're financially mad at
yourself yeah
now's the time oh by the way it happens
to be the best time to sell a house too
right now because this market's still
booming
it's a great time to sell very few times
in history can you say it's a great time
to buy and a great time to sell at the
same moment
but it is a unique time right now
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today rebecca is with us in
lafayette indiana
and she says on her screen here that
she's debt free congratulations rebecca
thank you so much dave it's good to talk
to you you too so do you guys call it
lafayette or lafayette
uh lafayette okay
i figured
that's why i said it all right how come
tell me about your dad how much did you
pay off um well when i started doing
your plan i paid off thirty six thousand
dollars in two years but the total was
actually forty thousand
okay and what what do you make what
should have been your range of income
during that two years uh range of income
has been 22 000
starting two years ago and then now i'm
making 50. good for you nice job
doubling your income what do you do for
a living
um so i started off working at a bank
which is uh 12 hours that's the twenty
two thousand and now i'm a web developer
so total pivot yeah nice way to go
way to go
translation banker starved to death
isn't that weird i love it
i'm curious well again i was giving
loans out to people and now i i'm glad
that i'm out of that business because i
don't think i could in good conscience
give out loans
what kind of debt was your 36 000
uh it was four thousand dollars in
credit card loans and the rest was in
two months okay so what was your wake-up
call what happened two years ago they
got you on this boat
um so i had a couple of friends who have
been great in accountability and
introduced me to you i thought that your
ideas were crazy they are and i very
reluctantly got on the debt uh free plan
but i actually didn't have my i've had
it moment until last year and so i
started doing the plan started cutting
down my income and putting the rest
towards the loans but then um as i was
living off of basically sixteen thousand
dollars a year and the rest was going
towards my loans i was watching my
family and my parents you know who had
car loans and two time shares and
they're kind of living and rolling in
this debt and here i was trying to pay
off my debt and they they were
complaining saying oh we don't have
money for things and we're gonna you
know we're having trouble with our
finances and i looked at them and i said
well it's because you have debt and they
thought i was crazy
you became one of those people didn't
you
they said that that's a part of your
life and that you just need to let it
live with you and i said they were crazy
and so that's when i i had my i've had
it moment because i realized i didn't
want to be like my parents
yeah all of a sudden these debt-free
ideas aren't weird they're yours
yeah yeah so we're so proud of you
that's awesome very cool rebecca what
was the training like to to become a
developer for you um
a lot of a lot of
breaking sites um i've learned a lot of
codes along the way and so i didn't my
degree actually was not in web
development and so it's been a long
journey with paying for a degree i'm not
using and then now learning coding and
so um right now i'm just basically using
html and css but um i'm hoping that in
the future i can learn a lot more
because i love the field i'm in that's
awesome and really good good for you
good good track for you very very good
very cool so now you did it you you're
got rid of all the debt how's it feel
yes
how does it feel it feels amazing i
cannot believe the relief that i feel
when i wake up in the morning and i
realize that i can make plans with my
money and i'm able to
look into the future and make goals and
priorities and it's just it's an amazing
feeling wow how old are you i'm 26. good
for you that's incredible well done very
well done so when people say this now
people like your parents they go okay
you pay off 36 000 worth of debt you
started out making 22 000 now you're
making 50.
how do you do that what are the keys to
getting out of debt what do you tell
them
um i tell them that it's really good to
have a good support network and even
though my parents weren't there for me
and think i'm crazy i did have a couple
of friends who were with me every step
of the way and so it's good to look for
a community of people and i'd also say
that
keep getting back on the horse there
were so many times i failed and so many
times i went over my budget with my fun
money budget or and i had to cut that
down and cut that down and it got so
discouraging not being able to go out to
eat and having to turn down friends and
family members because i didn't have
enough gas
and
i just want to say it's worth it it's
worth it getting back on the horse over
and over and over because now i can
stand here and i can live my life being
completely free of debt and it's amazing
all right way to go kiddo proud of your
hero
well done touchdown hey we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you uh how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too that's the next
chapter in your story for sure you are
on your way
you're going to be making 100 in two
years because you're going to keep
learning this code
and uh
and and of course you're going to have
no debt you're on your way to be a
millionaire way to go i also got a copy
of
the total money makeover for you to give
away to someone and um that'll help them
get on the road too because they'll be
inspired by your story and we're going
to give you a one-year subscription to
financial peace university i want you to
go through the whole class and make sure
you learn everything about money because
you're going to be having a whole bunch
of it around you and you need to be
handling it well we're going to show you
how to do every every bit of that so
rebecca thank you so much well done all
right rebecca from indiana 36 000 paid
off in two years making 22 to 50 count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two five
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go kiddo pretty cool way to go
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping
new promos all the time you save money
all the time use the promo code ramsey
when you go to blinds.com today's
question comes from justin in arizona my
wife and i are in our 50s and our
combined income is 145. we own a rental
property free and clear that's worth 600
000 and generates 1900 a month our
primary residence is worth 1.1 million
and we currently owe 268 on it we have
no other debt we have 45 000 in cash and
savings and i have 60 000 in retirement
funds my father recently passed away and
i will soon be receiving his 1 million
dollar life insurance benefit i was
going to immediately pay off our
mortgage but what should i do with the
remaining 732 000 should i invest all of
it and draw a decent amount each year
without touching the principal i'm
devastated by the loss of my father and
don't want to do the wrong thing
with this gift
sorry to hear about your father justin
that's really tough but what a what a
legacy he left by taking care of his
finances and helping bless you guys to
catapult your financial journey
yeah
so one million dollar life insurance
benefit they owe 268 on their primary
residence they have a rental property
free and clear this is a good spot to be
in so i absolutely would pay off the
mortgage today and he's asking what to
do with the remaining money and if you
guys don't have any other things you
need to be doing upgrading cars or house
renovations i absolutely would invest it
[Music]
i also would give a gift to some
ministry that in honor of your dad
and i so i picked so it doesn't have to
be you decide the amount it doesn't have
to be a huge amount but
uh giving
enjoying some of the money and investing
the money
uh always you always want to be looking
at all three things
at all times have some balance people
who don't do one of those
leave and live an incomplete life
you don't you're not generous or you
don't enjoy it or you never invest it
in any of those cases you're going to
leave something out here and you're
going to get a flat tire so yeah exactly
you're not it's not a well-rounded
situation so
yeah i'm with george let's pay off the
mortgage and then sit down with
smartvestor pro put some money in mutual
funds i i would allocate
you know i don't know 20 50 000 bucks
you know do some kind of wild travel
thing you've always wanted to do
or that classic car you always wanted or
something i'd spend some of it don't
have to be a lot
but a little bit enjoy the money and
then i'd take another another little
chunk of money i don't know uh 15 20 30
50 000 whatever something like that and
i'd find something to celebrate the life
of your dad
with a donation to some wonderful
ministry that does something that was
close to him yeah or that represented
him so always giving always enjoying
always investing and always debt free
and these are the things we're always
going to lead you to the end of those
into that realm
so good stuff justin again sorry for the
loss of your dad but as george said what
a wonderful legacy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today joe is in salem oregon hi
joe how are you
i'm good hold on
yes speaker
i'm 58 years old and my husband is 68
he's a retired teacher so
we have a pers retirement
that's generous and so
we have that he we got it for my
lifetime because i'm younger than him he
also took social security at age 65
and we let his life insurance expire so
my concern is that um
we don't have much in savings we um our
only debt is our mortgage which is about
144 000. good lord um
yeah we have um an ira which is down to
i don't know 52-ish thousand right now
and then i started a roth ira a couple
years ago and i'm not sure i haven't
checked it but maybe 10 to 15 000.
and my husband
feels like um because we have the
monthly income
unless purse falls apart that we don't
need to save anything and the ira is for
going on vacations or two of our kids
got married last summer we used it for
that too
and so it just keeps going down
and i
myself i um
i make frugality in art form so i it
stresses me out to not have something he
keeps asking me why why do we need
something what kind of emergency and i
said i don't know but i just feel like
if something happened to you and i'd
have to sell the house i don't
necessarily want to so funerals illness
transmissions go out on cars i mean how
many times do we have to name it a root
canal what kind of i mean i can name you
about 73 emergencies in 73 seconds
yeah so how naive for somebody 68 years
old
yeah i so i've been paying a little
extra on the mortgage when i can but we
have we have never put 15 percent
towards our investments yeah um and how
old are you you said you're 50 something
i'm 58. are you working
i work part-time so
you know i bring in maybe 9 000 a year
i've always worked part-time a little
bit just to make things an end to me
because we lived off of
his salary and raised four kids and we
were able to do it and i always tell
people that they can do it if i can live
off a teacher's salary then you know
they can do it but we didn't have a lot
of okay so what is that what is your
household income today with the pension
the social security and the 9 000
part-time work
it was 122 last year but that included
taking no that included what we took out
of the ira so it's probably like 110.
okay you guys have to pay off this house
girl
so is that more urgent than oh you need
to be you need to be saving 15 000 a
year you need to do two roth iras and
you need to be paying off the house
that's not frugality that's wisdom
so at our age is it too late to be
putting into iowa because he has to
start taking let's see what options do
you have
going back and starting again oh wait a
minute that's not an option
you're breathing you need a paid for
house you're breathing you need some
money and investments
right old doesn't mean you don't do it
so do we put more into the loft into the
regular ira or the roth ira i would do
two roth iras
with you as the beneficiary on both of
them
you're almost 10 years younger
and i i would get and i would then i'd
pour everything else onto the house
um are we able to convert the
traditional you can but i wouldn't i
just leave it sitting there
my god live on that
i know but he are you able to work more
he wants me to retire
so that we can i don't know what his
plan is does he have secret money that
we don't know about
no he put in his years as a teacher and
he wants to and he wants to play golf
and have fun okay play golf and have fun
within a budget
yeah because it ain't fun when he dies
and you're broke
yeah you're trying to make mortgage
payments that's why you called
yeah because your bells are ringing down
inside of your soul saying this is bad
this is bad this is bad and we are
telling you you're about you need to
listen to the bell it's right
okay so what percentage do i put towards
the roth i would do two roth iras that
you fully fund each of you
and then i would put everything else i
can squeeze out of my budget on this
house and don't you dare spend another
dime except out of your income beyond
those two things
so if he wants to travel or he wants to
do something you have to save up and do
it out of a hundred and ten thousand
dollar income
oh
okay i'm not sure i'm going to how i'm
going to tell him that
uh tell him you're 57 and he's 66 and
he's going to die and you don't want to
be left with nothing
no
that's how i feel that's exactly right
this is an act of love on his part to
now start being a grown-up
a little late but it's time
i know i've told him this before and he
doesn't he doesn't see it well i can't i
can't make your husband grow a brain
honey i'm just telling you what you need
to do
okay so you that'll be your job to put
his big boy pants on yeah i mean show
him that he loves you at some point this
guy needs to actually quit being sad gum
selfish and immature
and you know love your wife well sir
you know it's a that comes first man i
mean you know it's just then you can
play golf and then you can do the other
stuff and but you've done a horrible job
at saving money you're 66 years old you
still have a mortgage
and so you know you've not earned the
right to be a playboy and fly around the
world you don't have any money
they got a mini retirement which means
mini golf sorry we're going to be on a
different kind of budget putt-putt is
all that's legal here
goodness gracious
oh boy
sorry i had to do it it was underhand
pitch all right alex it's a short putt
hey alex what's up
hey dave how are you good man how can we
help
good i um i'm considering going back to
college and pursuing an
associate's degree and what i'm about
business
why
i was looking to be a sports agent so i
wanted to get some
business knowledge before pursuing a
finance degree
do you think you have to have a finance
degree to be a sports agent
no
um i just wanted to
pursue that i have about uh 22 000 in
debt and i wasn't sure should i just pay
off my debt yes or should i go ahead and
attack that first yeah soon knock that
dead out what are you making now
i'm making about 3 300 a month in net
what do you do
i'm i'm a vendor so i deliver food
snacks and drinks right now okay and
you're single
yes how old are you
okay
and so where's the sports agent thing
come from what made you want to do that
um i realized that i have a love for
negotiating and i also love sports so i
figured i'd put the two together and
um okay
do you know any sports agents
uh not personally no okay i would make
it a point to learn to meet one or two
immediately and see if you can't follow
one of them around or maybe you could be
their assistant or maybe you could be
whatever not to steal their customers
but to go in and learn how the business
works and you probably can make as much
as you're making now and start being
mentored in the business
right right that's a great idea yeah and
you know you can pick up a finance class
or to an accounting class or two and
just audit them here or there as you
move along this process and prepare
yourself to handle the numbers side of
the negotiations
and um that way you can keep one of your
athletes from getting paid in bitcoin or
something stupid but like that
boy that's some funny stories out there
on that but um
end up working for nothing this year
yeah did you okay oh and went to the
super bowl who knew yeah but oh my god
uh all right so yeah uh
yeah that that's i love your plan
let's just come up with a way to execute
it so i don't think it has to be i mean
i think you can be working while you're
getting out of debt and you can start
moving towards and being around people
in the business ken coleman calls it the
proximity principle be in proximity of
the people that are doing the thing you
want to do
and so you kind of get to get it on you
kind of get to see it feel it
even if you're the if you're the janitor
in a sports agency organization at least
you're in the building
you know
and that that's what ken talks about so
i'm gonna send you a copy of his book
proximity principle and i would start
moving towards this career without
necessarily moving through a bunch of
classes right now
and let's get these debts knocked out
while you're doing that
so george good show good stuff good
stuff today good hour that puts this
particular hour in the books our thanks
to austin ben zak andrew and james in
the booth and kelly i'm dave ramsey your
host and we'll be back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we're here to help people build wealth
do work that they really love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
on any of those subjects the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five george campbell ramsey
personality and host of the fine print a
podcast on the ramsey networks is my
co-host today again open phones here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
jacob starts us off this hour in atlanta
hi jacob welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey so i just um
graduated college
i am originally from a small town in
georgia i'm moving to atlanta
got my first job as a financial analyst
making around 65 000 a year
i plan on staying in atlanta for around
five to ten years
and i know
that renting would be easier i'm trying
to start off on a rent or to buy a condo
i understand that obviously renting
gives you the flexibility but buying the
condo at least you retain some of that
equity um so i guess i'll love some
advice
cool well congratulations on graduating
with a fantastic job that's awesome you
got any debt
no debt um i did uh army rotc
um in college so i just commissioned as
a officer in the reserve
so huge blessing right how much money do
you have
um so i have around a hundred thousand
dollars in total assets about twenty
thousand dollars in the bank and then
the rest on the other eighty thousand
dollars is uh
in index funds
wow good for you well done where'd you
learn all this stuff
so i heard about you a long time ago um
you actually i influenced my brother a
lot and then he got me caught onto that
when i was in a freshman in high school
um so yeah just you know saving every
penny and investing it essentially
you've done really well man so that's
where you're what you're what 22.
uh i'm actually 21 about 1022 yes yeah
good for you sharp young man yeah i
would rent for a year
and let's just get settled into the new
gig and settle into this post-college
phase of your life
and that will probably inform
where you want to live before you buy
you learn the traffic patterns in
atlanta which would be
information that you want
you don't want a two-hour commute to
work right and so uh and you're gonna
kind of figure out the area of town
you're gonna run in where you're gonna
hang where your buddies are gonna be
where you're gonna go church whatever it
is you're gonna do
and what your social network looks like
and that's gonna you know kind of
settling into the city a little bit for
a year is gonna help you pick a better
condo
one year from today and during that time
you can pile up a bunch of cash you're
almost gonna pay cash for this thing
right no absolutely that was my plan was
to try to put as much cash you know yeah
how to get close to 40 50 for a down
payment yeah i'm thinking you know you
got 80 now you got your emergency fund
and you know you all you got's rent and
you're making good money you're used to
living like a college student so you're
not going to spend out your years i hope
and uh yeah you ought to be able to you
ought to be able to pile onto that 80
pretty healthy in a year what do you
think you could add to it
um you know i'm trying that was that was
another kind of question i had like i
was thinking about do the 25 i know
you're 25 after tax school does that
still apply to buying as well yes um
because i'm hoping gotcha because i'm
hoping to add i don't know
probably at least
15 to 20 more thousand is the goal yeah
and then and then it'll probably grow
another 15.
give or take so during this year so
yeah i'm thinking next spring you start
looking around and i just think you'll
know
uh your way around
uh atlanta and the world a lot more than
you do today one year out of college
right
right no absolutely 100
and uh and then the other thing i'll
warn you of is um
if you were to meet uh uh
your future wife
and uh start dating
and get married you will discover that
you have bought the wrong condo at that
point
you will be notified
and so you will you'll sell it and
you'll make some good money and you'll
buy where you should have bought that
you didn't know
the cabinets will be the wrong color
somehow no i'm just it's a it's a joke
but it's also just a lot of truth so
good wisdom yeah jacob is with us no
that was jacob talking to you
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five the housing
market we were just talking about it
over the last couple of years has been
unique
uh the federal reserve is up the ante
raise the federal funds rate again uh
it's got a lot of people worried if you
want to learn about all of this stuff go
to ramseysolutions.com rates
and if you're ready to buy or ready to
sell
we were talking about it in another hour
george this is a unique time in real
estate
the real estate rhythms the rhythms of
the real estate market usually it's a if
it's a good time to buy
it's a bad time to sell if it's a good
time to sell it's a bad time to buy
buyers
exactly usually got one or the other and
we're kind of like coming up over the
rise on an apex we're kind of at the
balancing point right now
um it's been a seller's market for a
while a shortage of housing and there
still is a shortage
of housing there's still more demand
than there is supply but demand has
cooled off in the last
uh
60 days dramatically
compared to say this time last year
and um is that a major part due to the
interest rates going up it's just the
economy is cooled in general yeah
interest rates are up inflation people
are sitting on the sidelines and so it
there's still more buyers than there is
sellers
but it's nowhere near like it was so the
what that is going to give us is it's
going to slow down the price jumps
this these insane you know increases in
price and the competition they're going
to slow down 50 over asking and crazy
offer it's going to slow down it's going
to you're going to get you're going to
see more normal price increases now
so it's a but it's still a really good
time to sell because the market is still
hopping okay it's also uniquely a good
time to buy
because
the uh you know
some buyers are saying you know we're
gonna wait on prices to come down prices
are not coming down on houses
if you go you have to you can only you
can't find times in history that a
recession or high interest rates have
caused house prices to go down let me
give you an example
in 1982 interest rates on houses had
under jimmy carter had gone to 18 17.5
fixed rate whoa
house prices didn't go down
they stayed
and that weird
so interest rates going up will not
necessarily cause house prices to go
down and that's an extreme i mean we're
right now at five and a half six
not at 18. which feels crazy because
they've been so low in the past yeah it
feels like because they've been a three
you know but uh but but you know
interest rates are gonna cause this this
housing bubble to burst i'm gonna wait
on prices to go down
you're dealing with a false hypothesis
that's not going to occur you ladies and
gentlemen okay so five years from today
every year from now for the next five
years the val the price of a house is
going to go up so this is as good a time
as there ever was if you're in a
position if you're out of debt you have
your emergency fund you have your down
payment
go to ramseysolutions.com click on elp
and get you an agent and go buy a house
right now it's a good time to buy a
house well interest rates might go down
well if they go down refinance and get
rid of that mortgage okay this is a good
time as ever to sell because the
market's still hopping go today go to
rmcsolutions.com get you an elp an
endorsed local provider get that house
on the market this is as good a time as
you're going to see in the next five
years to sell a house right now
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today you jump
in we'll talk about your life and your
money
so george um
not only has uh bitcoin dropped what
60-something percent now since september
big crash um
that's not six that's 60
percent ouch
that means you turned 100 000 into 40.
uh but now we're seeing that a billion
dollars has been lost in crypto scams
according to the federal trade
commission
this is wild
cryptocurrency scammers have stolen over
1 billion dollars from 46 000 people
since the start of 2021 a new federal
trade commission report says ftc rang
the alarm bells on friday saying
crypto-related crimes amount to about
one out of every four dollars reported
lost to fraud more than any other
payment method the meeting individual
reported loss was twenty six hundred
dollars this is wild
um
crypto scams are becoming increasingly
popular shooting up 60 times higher than
in 2028
uh nearly half of those who reported
losing money to a crypto scam in 2021
says they were lured in
through an online post or a social media
message so how are they getting scammed
do you know well on facebook and
instagram they lure you in
with you know they get you to
click the link go to a website and
there's been a lot of actual space scam
accounts impersonating me
trying to message people about crypto
and the people know it's spam and scams
once they go george is telling me to
invest in crypto i know this is a scam
so they report it and they let me know
dave ramsey's only get a credit card
exactly
not a great move to the scammers out
there
and so that's what's happening and so
people get lured in and they go well
this seems you know this seems like a
good deal it seems like i'm going to win
big on this thing so they click it and
they give them access to their crypto
wallets and all kinds of things and also
what are they what are they what are
they why would what are they buying i
mean what's the scam what are the what's
the pitch i have no idea what th there's
all kinds of different ones out there uh
across the board
i don't know they have any details uh
here in both cases scammers promise
substantial returns to their investors
but instead pocketed the money into
their own crypto wallets so they're
promising you hey give us the money
we're going to give you an amazing
return on your money into this new
crypto coin
and all of a sudden those returns
disappear and they pocket the money
instead
and this is happening all over
in february a federal grand jury in san
diego indicted the founder of bit
connect
for allegedly orchestrating a 2.4
billion dollar global ponzi scheme
founders accused of misleading investors
about the cryptocurrencies lending
program claiming the company prop
companies proprietary technology would
bring substantive returns to investors
by tracking cryptocurrency exchange
markets
so they all come down to this false
promises of easy money paired with
people's limited crypto understanding
and experience
so no one truly understands it and they
go well wait wait wait you're saying
someone who bought crypto would fall for
false promises of easy money i just read
the article i can't believe that don't
come at me in the comment section
but that's the truth
it's so new it's so volatile the
technology is there and so people are
going well this is my chance but kind of
my point is is the very person who buys
crypto to start with
uh is looking for a cutting edge easy
uh
sophisticated technologically
uh
easy money
uh and so when someone presents them
with another cutting edge sophisticated
thing then they're more likely to fall
for that than the average joe because
they already are biting it they're
already chewing on that hook they're
trying to get it on the ground floor of
the next thing they're trying to choose
the winning coins in other words the
scammers are taking them through the
same
psychological door that they went
through to buy bitcoin in the first
place and then they get scammed so
they're more susceptible
to scams and it's not it's all
unregulated so you're not protected
there's no fdic here going hey we'll
cover your money
and so you just lose this money
that's it
it's not hard
to steal people's crypto man
we've come a long way since the nigerian
prince this is the modern day version
[Laughter]
at least i got a nice nicely worded
email from the nigerian prince i
remember getting uh
copies on a bad copy machine by snail
mail from the nigerian prince wow that
took effort yeah they and well it had my
name
personalized across the top of this mo
of this copy that had been made like
eight thousand times so it had the
little lines and stuff on it because you
could tell it was like it's like a
mimeograph machine or something like
that yeah i'm old enough i used to get
those from the nigerian prince i kind of
miss those days simpler times in the
scamming world simpler times what was
the one it wasn't the spanish flu it was
the spanish lottery or something that
ran through canada really it was another
one you know that was well about 30
years of doing this you've seen lots of
scams
yeah
so uh glenn frashy who wrote the book
con man or saint
we talk about this in the building
wealth live event um he um
was claiming he might be a saint but he
wrote the book from prison so i'm
suspecting he was wrong um that he was
probably a comment he ran he ran a ponzi
scheme a true pyramid scheme and got put
in jail for it in the 70s
and um but he he was uh he was a
world-class con man
and uh
he said one of the quotes i read that
book you know when i was a teenager
i don't know how i ended up with it but
um
the quote i remember from the book more
than anything else i went and pulled it
out for this event that we're doing that
he said you can con
someone of any intellect
any level of education
if you can activate greed or fear
[Music]
and um
and they also they um
and really in a sense the part of the
greed one is pride
you know like you're in on something the
cool kids are in on it nobody except the
cool kids are in on it and you're one of
the cool kids you know you're not
you know people who aren't sophisticated
don't understand bitcoin
and uh you're obviously sophisticated
because you understand bitcoin and so
you're in bitcoin and since you're in
bitcoin we're going to give you this
other opportunity here it's your host
a billion
dollars
in
scam
oh not to mention
how many billions is it is it over a
trillion now
in lost value that it went down 60
percent yeah
so the total market value loss
of bitcoin i i read it it was an
astronomical number it's like a trillion
dollars or something when it went from
you know when it's gone down 60 percent
that means people uh had value at some
point that hypothetically they could
have cashed in somewhere and didn't
and so they have now ridden this thing
to the bottom yeah we're seeing some
really sad stories of how much people
are losing in this who they had a
million dollars in it and now they have
nothing i was just reading a
heartbreaking story about one guy who's
honest enough to share his losses which
is pretty rare most of them only brag
about the wins
well it's like a bad golf game or a
fisherman that's right which you never
had a bad golf game so you don't have to
worry about that never caught a fish
either never
but it's pretty wild stuff so i mean you
know we talk about buyer beware but with
crypto it's a whole nother animal
because there's a whole technological
piece that most people don't understand
and i think i'm a pretty smart guy and
the more i look into crypto the more
confusing it gets
and i think they did that on purpose
no
that's like whole life it's really
complicated on purpose because well you
don't have to worry about it it gets
complicated just trust me give me the
premiums i'll give you the rest
trust me
trust me
yes oh man this is trying to find out
what this thing has done let's see here
in one
year
the losses yeah it's it's astronomical
this is wrong okay i was trying to pull
it up on a website while i'm away that's
a dumb thing to do i'll tell you the
this guy he reportedly
uh he has a whole threat on twitter how
i went from a crypto millionaire to
broke in six months due to leverage a
gambling addiction and an accelerating
negative spiral
and he goes through in the thread about
every single piece of the puzzle that
caused him to lose this million dollars
and now he's got nothing
he's sad he could have retired he could
have done a lot of things with that
money and that was a lot of regret
it's sad we like to make fun of crypto
but i don't like anyone losing a lot of
money that breaks my heart i won't be
hurt yeah but i am
um more than a little bit
um
as much criticism as we took over from
the crypto that's true from the crypto
kids little vindication yeah it's like i
kind of want to go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
josiah and anna are with us in wichita
kansas says on my screen you guys are
debt free congratulations
thank you yes we are how much you paid
off
we paid off 88
568 dollars good for you and how long
did that take about 34 months good for
you and your range of income during that
three years
we are first year married we started at
80 000 and then last year we were at 96.
good what do you do for a living
i'm a vegetarian technician i manage a
veterinary hospital and i work at ups
very good what kind of debt was the 89
000
well it would we started with 85 000 was
our mortgage and then added some medical
debt for um our first child okay so that
you paid off your house
yep yes we did wow
look at you weirdo
oh man
very good what's the house worth
um last appraised it was uh now worth
about 160. with the land wow good for
you guys you're 30 you're how old now
um i am 27 and 33. and you have a paid
for house yes you're so weird
i mean none of your friends have paid
for houses yeah it's pretty rare for our
age yeah no quote no question well done
you two
very well done okay so what starts this
journey at this young age for you guys
we got married
yeah
but i mean what made you decide you're
getting out of debt a lot of people get
married and they go in debt for 30 years
the major start was growing up both of
our sets of parents forced us to go
through financial peace all your
financial peace babies oh yes oh yes my
mom made us go through it two times wow
so when you started dating how long
before you compared notes and figured
out that both your parents were weird
well we actually grew up in the same
church so oh you already knew parents
were weird from the beginning you
already knew it's it's like a whole
group of weird i love it a whole group
of weirdos very cool i love you guys
that's awesomeness so yeah because of
our parents we were very blessed and we
got married already debt free just with
the house mortgage so
man and that set you guys up to where
you have paid four houses in your late
20s early 30s oh yeah yeah wow that's
incredible that's a changed family tree
back to their mom and dad yeah i mean
their mom and dad this is an extension
of the family tree that was changed with
mom and dad
it was it's the truth and actually it
started with my grandparents my grandpa
was the first one to bring financial
peace to our church and whoa
dave are you that old
you're a financial piece of grandbabies
oh my god yes we are yes
our kids one day will continue the trend
man that's amazing my
great-great-grandpappy went through fbu
that's great i like it that's fantastic
i like it you guys this is so cool very
neat
very neat okay so i don't know um what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is have great smart
grandparents i don't know what do you
what's the uh what do you guys think the
key to getting out of debt is you did it
you mean 34 months you knocked out 89
000. well we said that you've just got
to stay focused on it because actually
on paper when we were budgeting when we
were engaged we were set to do it in
less than two years
but then after we got married it was
just kind of a oh well this will only
add one more month so we'll do this and
then at the end of that first year we
realized we had not made the progress we
should have and so we just kind of
buckled down and got it done after that
well and you go ahead and have some
babies while you're at it right well
yeah that too yeah maybe later that day
that might slow it down a little
and uh the first one had a few medical
bills huh
yeah just a regular
there was he was fine just regular the
hospital bill and then we were we had
enough saved up cash flow number two
here oh yeah all right so yeah that way
the second one's not in danger of repo
no okay you say a few weeks ago
yep ten weeks ago our daughter was born
oh congratulations oh she's precious we
just see her on youtube
actually
i made him promise when we got married
that when we were debt-free we were
going to come visit you there in
tennessee and he forgot
that he'd promised
but the timing didn't work out for us to
be there
live but we were actually there last
wednesday met you and got a book signed
oh my goodness oh my gosh
we should have worked that out oh my
goodness now
it worked out he kept his promise and we
get to do to do this with you so yeah
wow you guys are amazing i'm so proud of
you congratulations
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story um we're going to
give you a one-year subscription to
financial peace university which you
need to give away because your whole
family has been doing this for
generations
and so you can get somebody else on this
train man that's so cool and same with
the total money makeover book we'll send
that to you as well give you some things
you can pay it forward with i'm so proud
of you guys what a great story grandpa
brings financial peace to them that
thing they meet it to the church they
meet at the church after their parents
have gone through it then they both are
required to go through it as teenagers
and now they're 27 years old with a paid
for we're going to see more financial
peace grand babies here i'm telling you
man they're right there yeah i'm liking
it way to go guys good inspirational
stuff all right josiah and anna wichita
kansas 89 thousand dollars paid off in
34 months house and everything
weirdos
and making 80-96 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
man oh man oh man
wow
you know when i was first
doing this stuff myself
i i you know we had gone broke we lost
everything
starting to build a little bit of wealth
back up
and you know clearing off the irs and
some other debt that survived the
bankruptcy and uh so that we're
debt-free and we're starting to go and
i'm just like okay
we're gonna handle money
god's in grandma's ways with common
sense
the the culture thing is going to think
i'm crazy but you know once you've been
broke you don't care what other people
think
and
but one of the things georgia went
through my head was
i am going to change my family tree this
is the last ramsay in this branch
that's going to have debt
because i'm going to have so much wealth
built up and i'm going to teach them
generationally
and make it a thing a ramsey family
thing that we handle money with
integrity and with maturity and with
wisdom without debt and someday
you know i'll see my grandkids and at
that point my rachel was a baby you know
someday i'll see my grandkids as adults
and they will never see a mortgage
they will never see debt they will never
see it we're gonna you know we're
breaking this down
and little did i know that i'm gonna get
to meet people like josiah and
anna that that are third generation
going through financial peace university
and so now that's happening for their
family and millions of other families
like theirs
all over america so it wasn't just my
little dream of me
nev no one in my lineage ever having
dead again now that that that's broken
that's
those kids right there man that's very
cool the ripple effect of that decision
you made many many years ago to go never
again how that's affected so many
millions of people
and uh you raised some great kids on top
of that and but the point is that
everybody listening can just decide the
same thing today
as for me and my house
no more
i'm done
no more
i'm not gonna do what this crazy butt
lost its mind culture
have you all noticed that people in
america have lost their minds
i mean they're crazy
there's just some weird wacky stuff
going out there that people are acting
like everybody should go along with
i mean it's just nutty out there
and so you know we
those of us the children of common sense
have to stand up you know well people
call us crazy and at this point i'm just
going to choose my crazy and i'm going
to choose the one that's filled with
peace no anxiety wealth legacy
i'll choose that crazy every day over
what's going on in the culture agreed
agreed and uh you know it's
i do not need to keep up with the toxic
culture the toxic culture has lost its
mind
in virtually every category
every department
is cray-cray and so it's just you know
we we were not that far
lost
all of us 20 years ago that all you
people that have come along in the last
20 years decided you're going to
straighten all of us out
no you're the crazy ones and we are
calling you out now we're saying you're
nuts
and we don't want to be like you you're
crazy
i don't be like you
it's nutty out there and i don't need to
be like you if you don't like it i'm
fine with that because i don't want i
don't
just be mad that's perfectly good with
me you know we'll choose our crazy like
george said choose the good kind yeah
i'm gonna choose the common sense kind
of crazy this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 11 14
where there is no guidance a nation
falls
but in an abundance of counselors there
is safety
admiral nimitz said leadership consists
of picking good men and helping them
do their best
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today zach's in kansas city hi
zach how are you
hey i'm doing pretty good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
hey uh so about a year ago i had to step
away from school after falling on hard
times and
i recently found out that my outstanding
balance with the school was about to be
collected on
and now i'm in a bit of a better
position to pay
a lot of that off i was wondering if
i should let it be collected and maybe
negotiate and kind of get a deal from
the collectors rather than just try and
pay it all with the school
well um you know i'd go i'd call the
school and offer them a deal
just don't it sounds like it sounds like
your real story like the truth
would be a good
story okay you know i fell on hard times
i had to abandon you know my pursuit of
the degree
and so you know so for the money i have
spent there i'm getting nothing
and i've saved up a little i don't have
it all
but if you guys would like to do a
settlement i can write you a check today
and make this call call it a day
and i'm asking i'm asking for some mercy
yeah
how much do you owe that
uh right now it's six thousand dollars
okay how much money do you have
uh right now i have six thousand dollars
yeah call them and settle it
d deal with it now be done with it don't
screw some collector
awesome get a hold of somebody get a
hold of somebody in leadership in
administration at the school
how big a school
it's a a pretty big school um
i don't know the population but uh it's
a pretty big school yeah okay
all right so like kansas or kansas state
or something like that
yeah okay all right yeah just call them
just talk to the admissions office and
say who do i talk to about clearing this
debt settling this debt and then just
talk to them and go hey listen do i need
to talk with like your boss or something
because i don't know how this works i
don't want to soldier or something but
what do i who have i got to talk to
that's got the power to do this because
here's the situation i went through this
this and this and i had to leave school
because of that and tell them the whole
story don't not not a 30-minute version
but a four-minute version
and go and i'm honestly i mean i've got
a little bit of money i'm still
basically broke but i want to settle
this and do what's right and try to try
to clear the debt can you guys help me
with some mercy
gotcha and uh i'm going to do just that
do what
i'm going to do just that i think yeah
yeah i think it'll work
i mean i don't i it might not you might
just have to write a six thousand dollar
check but either way you're done right
right yeah i'm i'm gonna go ahead and
get out of dodge and put this in your
rear view mirror and move on with your
life i think your life will be better
not having this hanging over your head
and having to screw with somebody for
the next six or eight months waiting to
hand it to collections to maybe get two
thousand dollars saved or something yeah
move on with your life
there's a power there's a
a financial benefit to cleanliness
in your life
not having your head cluttered and
things chasing you from the rear view
you know you just there's no ghosts in
the closet no monsters in the closet you
know it's not worth the brain space the
emotional energy your time it takes to
even fight all this you got the money
you can concentrate on the future in
winning instead of concentrating
on the using your bandwidth on the
monsters
uh gerald is with us in new york city hi
gerald how are you
i'm doing well dave how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
so i'm getting married in august uh
fiance and i are both debt-free paid off
a little bit over a hundred thousand
dollars in debt which is awesome way to
go on the wedding of course way to go
thank you
um so my question for you just kind of
thinking ahead um you know eventually
we're going to settle down and we're
going to look to get a house
i know you recommend putting down 20
but i was thinking me being the saver
if we can
save more than 20 percent is it
beneficial to put that down or should we
take that extra that we saved and just
add it to our fully funded emergency
fund or even invest it
i would absolutely put it towards the
house we we did something very similar
we put down 45 on our house and it
allowed us to pay it off a whole lot
faster and that's the goal you paid it
off in what two three years 26 months 26
months
and part of that was because we worked
on the front end like you did we're so
diligent to save up and put a giant
number down and so that's only going to
help you because number one it's going
to be a smaller mortgage payment every
single month which allows you to have
more margin to put on top of that so i
love this plan you guys are crushing it
yeah that's that's very very wise that's
very smart
yeah um
to the george plan
all right bill is with us bill's in uh
midland michigan hey bill what's up
hey how's it going i've got a quick
question for you my wife and i are both
self-employed and we set up ross
roth iras last year
and just wondering if other than that
because there's obviously only a limit
of what you can invest into that per
year um what other best investment
options are for being a self-employed
people you have employees
uh i do not i'm a self-employed massage
therapist and she has she has two
employees she's along the across the gym
okay all right
for you it's a no-brainer i would do a
roth sep a simplified employee pension
plan an scpp okay okay and you can put
up to 13.6 of your net profits in
addition to your roth ira into that and
you can do it as a roth and you can do
it in mutual funds sit down with your
smartvestor pro click smart investor at
ramseysolutions.com and sit down with
one of those guys or gals and they can
lead you right through that process now
the sep has a requirement that whatever
percentage
you put in
you have to put in the same percentage
of the employees income that have been
with you
more than three of the last five years
okay so if you've got if your wife has
employees that have been with her more
than three years
and she puts in 10 into a sep she's got
to put 10 of their income into their so
it doesn't work real good then
sure okay she would be better off to do
what's called a simple
ira
and a simple ira is a 401k for very very
small businesses
it doesn't cost much to set up
and you can fund a fund it up to 401k
numbers
but you're required to match up to three
percent of the employees
the money that they put in
okay if they put nothing in you've got
nothing in it and you've just got a good
plan but that three percent match is
nowhere near as much as you'd have to
put in with a sep if you've got
employees have been with you a long time
and you can set that up as a roth as
well so probably a sep for you probably
a
a simple ira
which is a 401k for small businesses uh
for her
and she's going to have that mandatory
match but either way you can get a lot
more money in between those two things
you know what twenty thousand what's the
matter 20
500 on it for her okay for her that'll
be the max on hers and yours will max
out at like almost 30 000 but it's a
percentage of your profits is the max up
until you get to that limit and so you
can push push all that through smart
vester pro can teach you every bit of
that they can lay it all out for you you
can pick the same mutual funds you put
in your roth or different ones if you
want
and try to do them all as roths as well
but uh you you can get a lot more money
into this stuff now reminder bill if
you're a baby step four you still got a
house mortgage
you don't put more than 15 percent of
your household income into all of these
retirements combined
so that's your max because we want to
put everything past that
into paying off the mortgage as fast as
possible yeah and a good reminder for
those that are self-employed that you do
have options i've got some messages this
week and people are going i'm
self-employed so i guess i can't retire
and i can't save for retirement and so
what they have they don't know that
these options even exist those are great
that that little simple ira that little
401k plan for small business is an
incredible product we used that here for
a long time and we hit the max's on the
the size of the plan that required us to
go into a more traditional 401k which is
fairly expensive to operate for the
company
but that's good certain scales that
little simple 401k is great great
product it's a and again get with smart
investor pro they can help you do every
bit of that george good show awesome
times thank you dave good job to austin
ben zack andrew james and kelly i am
dave ramsey your host will be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you